guides me through the Gloom with torch
in hand in Kirsten Central Hospital
every aspect of her work has been
impacted by the war and the liberation
of her City will not make things better
overnight
um
policy
they are short of everything here but
perhaps most of all power
even though it's daylight it's still
very dark in here there's only one
generator for the whole hospital when
they retreated from the city the
Russians destroyed the infrastructure
that provides basic services and it's
those with the greatest needs that are
suffering most
as we take into the Maternity Ward we
can hear the sound of War
the staff never get used to this trauma
they cannot Escape
inside the difficulties are acute
Aliana has just gone into labor and
keeping her warm is the priority for the
Medics it's improvised but it works
um
yulia's son Constantine came into the
world on Liberation day
the nurse helps to keep them warm using
bottles of hot water
um
the babies here were all conceived just
before the start of this war and for
nearly all of their pregnancies the
mothers were living under Russian
occupation
foreign
this war has been grinding on now for
nine long months but the mothers here
hope their children will grow up knowing
only freedom
Alex Rossi Sky News Kirsten